daniel jones injured a hamstring against
the bengals last week hasn't practiced
all week it would be colt mccoy here is
offensive coordinator jason garrett
talking about
colt mccoy the backup to daniel jones
i thought colt did a really good job
last week in the game just getting
comfortable and allowing us to function
as an offense and i thought he handled
himself really well and you know
depending on how this thing plays out
this week you know we'll try to get him
some work and some reps and if he does
have to play in the ball game this week
hopefully he'll be comfortable so you
look for things he's done in his past
that he's comfortable with uh with you
or with somebody else just when that
ball is snapped it's it's all
internalized in him he's just going out
there and playing football
jason garrett with the sean mcvay
shouting at the front of the meeting
room style to the press conference but
that's fine hey by the way mike mike
could jason garrett sell ice to eskimos
oh hey he managed to sell himself to the
joneses for a lot longer than most
people think so the answer that would be
yes uh
hey
the giants it's just weird i can't get
my brain around the fact that the giants
are a contender but in the grossly
watered-down nfc east they are i don't
know what the drop-off is from daniel
jones to colt mccoy is there a drop-off
peter
i think there's definitely a drop off
the way that daniel jones had been
playing you know he had not been turning
it over at the same rate that he was he
was playing with confidence
he's got the ability to play outside the
pocket
and again look i'm not saying he's a top
10 nfl quarterback but i think he was
really starting to play
at the level that the giants feel they
need to to make that long-term
commitment to him um and and look colt
mccoy
if you don't play for a long time you're
going to be rusty but
he was rg3 like rusty
and i don't think you want to go into
your game
in seattle if there's a chance and mike
look last night
on channel 4 the nbc affiliate in new
york they had a little bit of tape
on daniel jones throwing on a side field
yesterday and and moving around on a
side field uh at giant's practice
and
he actually looked pretty good
surprisingly good so i don't know
whether there's a chance he's gonna play
in this game or not you would think not
but
you know because look all he's gonna do
in a game that they're unlikely to win
anyway
uh is probably aggravate that injury
i always love
when coaches and gm's and teams say well
the trainer said he couldn't hurt it any
worse you know it was you know if we're
not going to play him if he's got a
chance to get hurt any worse than he is
it's a hamstring it needs time to heal
you know and and look i doubt sincerely
that this is a riskless venture for the
new york giants if they played daniel
jones at seattle that's why it's
probably wise to not play him but we'll
see what happens
yeah there's a line that if you cross it
with a hamstring strain it grabs its
back and it can be worse than it was
depending upon how hard you pull on that
muscle anybody that's ever had that and
i've had it it is hell you have just got
to get off of it for multiple weeks
until it's back to normal and then even
when you think it's back to normal it
may not be back to normal colt mccoy
anything but a normal career peter he
was the guy in cleveland for his first
two years started 13 games in 2011. no
starts anywhere in 2012 or 2013 four
starts in 2014 in washington no starts
2015 2016 2017 he had two in 2018 in
washington
one in 2019 in washington and he could
get his first start as a member of the
giants it's just a testament to the idea
that you know you don't have to be a
great quarterback to make
nfl money and spend a decade in the
league even though you never play all
that much there's a role out there for
the backup quarterback who rarely plays
and yeah it's probably a better job than
what the alternative would be
look rg3 is learning it right now if
you're a good guy inside the team
and uh you work hard you support the
starter
uh you do everything you can in your
team team team
you can make two million bucks a year
for a long time
you know what what other job can you
have in life
where you're off for five months a year
and you make two million dollars now i
don't know what rg3 makes i'm guessing
but that's about what he what he makes
i'm sure the point is
that those jobs are great jobs to have
plus you know you know
that at some point
during the course of a year there's
probably a
i don't know 40 50 60 chance that you're
gonna play meaningful snaps
in a game and so you better be ready and
so that to me
is what colt mccoy is facing and look uh
i don't think he's gonna go out and beat
seattle but he's a professional so who
knows the ultimate proof that this week
was one of the craziest we've
experienced for the nfl
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports